[Music]
intercalating this is talk about
javascript performance tuning secrets so
this is not so much about how to
structure your code in a way that it
runs quickly it's more about the tools
and techniques that you can use to begin
to evaluate and investigate performance
issues and so I'm assuming that you're
sort of familiar already with the basic
stuff and the dev tools like the
timeline panel and the profiler this is
going more into sort of more exotic
crazy stuff that you might not be as
familiar with some of it's a little
hacky some of it's a little bit tricky
and all that to get working but if
you're really in a tough bind with
performance and you're just desperate
for one little clue one of the most
scrap of information that might lead you
to an improvement and a fix these are
good tools to have in your tool kit so
because this talk is pretty short I'm
gonna fly over a lot of different
material I'm gonna try to post up some
links to further reading on this github
repo along with the slides there's
nothing there yet but hopefully by this
weekend there will be so me real quick I
started doing professional web
development back when Firefox was in 100
beta back when WebKit's javascript
engine sucks so badly that you couldn't
do anything with it things that really
come a long way since then these days I
work at Adobe on the brackets team
brackets is an open source code editor
that we're building for web developers
it's also written in JavaScript and it's
a pretty pretty serious app the rackets
UI is about a hundred thousand lines of
JavaScript code that's over ten
megabytes of J's files so it's a very
performance intensive app and that's
kind of where I'm coming from on all
this stuff so first of all why is this
even a complicated problem I mean it
seems like sort of naively you could
just do something like this right you
you record a start time you do some
stuff you record an end time you know
how how long it took right and we're
using that these higher resolution
performance measuring API is that are in
modern browsers you get sub millisecond
accuracy it's really cool but I think
there's basically two big problems with
this the first is that you know a lot of
times your JavaScript is running in the
browser and when you're running in the
browser there's a lot of other stuff
that happens after this code is done
like that or that or that
that so if what you actually care about
is how long it takes before the user
gets feedback visually on screen the
browser native rendering stuff is
actually very important and that's
from the bottleneck these days because
JavaScript is so darn fast that the
browser native side can actually be the
bigger performance issue so that's one
issue but then of course also you know
lots of people run JavaScript like on on
the server or in helicopters or other
crazy stuff and regardless of where
you're running and I think the second
issue comes into play and that is that
javascript is not actually what's
running on a CPU right there's this this
mystery black boxes JavaScript VM it
does a bunch of magic and make circa one
and that's actually what's running on
the CPU and for performance sensitive
code what goes on that black box can be
really important getting deeper insights
into there as valuable so I'll talk
about those two topics in turn first
kind of like getting inter tangled with
browser native rendering stuff and then
second the interaction between
JavaScript and the VM it's running in
I'll go through a number of topics in
each of these they're arranged roughly
in ascending order of craziness so we'll
go down the left column first and I'm
going on the right column and and then
it'll have a little bit of miscellaneous
stuff at the end the wrap-up so first of
all who hasn't seen the timeline panel
and is willing to admit it in front of
everybody here anyone no one brave
enough okay but that's good and so
hopefully everybody knows about this
frames view which is I think the the
most powerful visualization you can get
in there for things like animation
performance scrolling performance
anything that's really rendering
oriented okay so hopefully everyone's
familiar with that but here are some
things you might not know about the
timeline panel first of all you can
actually add your own custom annotation
to this panel so if you do consult a
timestamp you actually get these tick
marks that show up both in the overview
of the whole timeline capture and also
in the individual zoomed interview you
can also use slightly different code
console that time and time end to
actually insert your own little bars in
the view so you can basically begin to
layer on semantic annotations that are
specific to your code so it makes it
that much easier to parse so you're no
longer you're looking at this really
generic you sort of blinded you that the
browser gives you what's going on you
can now actually begin looking at this
in terms of what it means in your in
your app which is pretty pretty cool
stuff but one thing that's always
bothered me about the timeline panel is
that it's very manually driven workflow
right like you load your page you have
to click around in it you record some
data you scrub through it in the
timeline it's not really conducive to
things like continuous integration where
you might want to be you know checking
for performance regressions
automatically on every check-in and
things like that
but it actually turns out there is a way
to do that so this may not be widely
known but the timeline panel in fact
everything in the developer tools in
Chrome and WebKit is built on top of an
open API that's just in JSON format and
it exposes a socket connection so anyone
can connect to that remote debugging API
in fact in the brackets editor we use
that API for things like live
development and google has actually
built a testing framework on top of this
called the telemetry framework it's
basically a collection of Python scripts
and and templates for test cases that
let you do automated performance testing
using the same data feed that the
timeline panel gives you except in an
automated way it actually includes some
some pretty powerful UI automation
capability so you can do things like
simulating clicks and and scrolling
scrolling is a particularly tricky one
to simulate normally from JavaScript so
actually what they do here is that
there's a there's a special API that is
turned off in Chrome normally that when
the telemetry framework runs chrome it
passes a flag that enables a special API
just for simulating scrolling accurately
to get really good performance data
there so it's really cool stuff and
briefly the way it works is you you
write it up a JSON file that has like a
list of URLs and a list of actions in
the URLs and what you want to test in
them you know you can scroll different
parts of the document click on different
dom nodes that sort of thing
you need to get the chrome source code
you don't need to compile it but you get
the scripts out of there and then you
run you run these scripts and you pass
it your JSON file and and then it
actually spits out a JSON file with
performance data so simple as that if
you're looking for an example of how to
use this I think a great place to look
is the topcoat project which if anyone
was at CSS comp you would have seen a
little bit about that there it's an open
source CSS framework basically and
they're very very concerned with
performance rendering performance load
performance all that so they're doing
automated testing using this telemetry
framework you can see a great example of
how to use it there
and they've also built a spin-off
project which is the top code server
project it's basically a node server
that you can use to upload your
performer
results too and we'll track the results
over time and it presents a really nice
web view visualizing how your
performance is varying over time so it's
a really great project you can make use
of when you're using these api's also
there's some other cool stuff in the dev
tools the FPS meter continuous
repainting these are really invaluable
for assessing rendering performance I'm
not going to go into detail on them here
though there's a lot of great stuff you
can read up on the googles about this
definitely very useful if you don't know
about it similarly there's a mode where
you can see repaint rectangles overlaid
in the page and there's a mode where you
can see compositing layers annotated
with borders and grids on the page it
gives you really really great deep
insight into what's going on with
browser painting on the one hand and
browser compositing on the other hand
but again this is pretty well-documented
stuff so I'm not going to go into too
much detail on it right here the
question actually then I'm going to talk
about is what if this is what if this
isn't enough what if you need even more
deeper insight into what's going on with
rendering and compositing in the browser
how many people have seen this for you
before phew how many people like to know
how to read it all right cool it's gonna
do a whole joke or someone had their
hand up I was gonna be like put your
hand down if you work at Google that's
cheating but I guess no one hears from
Google so well so I'll give you a quick
tour of this well resolution okay this
is a lot like what you see in the
timeline panel except it's broken down
at a very low level by thread and so the
first thing to know is it's capturing
everything that's going on in the
browser including all tabs you have open
so you want to close every other tab to
get extraneous data out of here and then
you want to use the the task manager to
actually identify which which to which
process ID you care about for your tab
there's always going to be a few extra
ones in here I happen to know that for
this run that I already captured the
thread that I care about is 60 to 60 so
I'm just gonna go close all this extra
stuff here that I don't care about and
I'll just leave a couple the gp1 is
useful to see also so there are
basically two threads involved in
rendering on any given
browser tab there's a compositor thread
and the renderer thread which is
actually where the bulk of the work
usually happens that's where v8 runs
your JavaScript that's where layout
happens that's where repainting happens
but this doesn't really look like much
yet if you look at this is actually a
really big time scale it's like a like
three second capture so it's just a big
mash of stuff we want to be able to zoom
in and the quickest way to do that is to
hold down alt and use the mouse wheel
and you can begin zooming in and start
seeing this break down into individual
basically frame per frame units to
navigate further you pretend you're
playing quake and you use the a and the
D key to pan horizontally and you can
use W and s to zoom in and out so it's
like a video game it's a little crazy to
navigate and as we zoom in more we can
start seeing these individual frame by
frame units and if you look they're
broken down roughly in 16 and changed
millisecond intervals so that's this is
one frame right here and there's this
characteristic u-shape to it so
rendering a given frame starts on the
compositor thread and the bulk of the
work usually happens in the render
thread and then it basically wraps up on
the compositor threat again so when you
see one of these u shapes that's
generally a single frame from start to
finish so the way that you actually read
the data in here is this is basically a
stack trace on the native side so these
are different methods that are running
in in Chrome there's run task calls
begin frame on main thread which calls
animate on the one hand which calls into
v8 that's requestanimationframe
calls layout after that it calls update
layers etc so the width of the bar is
how long it took so you can begin to get
a really good sense here of what's the
self time versus the total time forgiven
method call broken down in a really low
level the colors don't actually mean
anything in particular that was pretty
confusing to me at first they're just
randomly assigned but the same method
consistently gets the same color
everywhere that it appears so it makes
it much easier to sort of skim through
repeated results more easily you'll also
see that as a GPU thread down here which
is sometimes in sync with what's going
on in your particular tabs compositor
and render threads but not always
because it's actually shared across the
whole browser and so it's usually
running at the same frame rate but
sometimes out of phase which is one of
the reasons that measuring rendering
latency is a lot trickier than regiment
during rendering frequency or framerate
an X on the GPU thread this is view is
going to be enhanced in a future version
of Chrome as they do some rendering
refactoring it's going to add more and
more tools to begin visualizing what's
going on with GPU textures and
individual repaint steps even so it's
pretty powerful this is sort of a
complement to the timeline panel though
it's not a replacement for it in fact
there's some cases where the timeline
panel gives you more information than
what you see here for example if you
hover over a repaint in the timelines
it'll show you overlaid on the page the
bounds of the repaint you can't get that
from chrome tracing and same thing with
layout you can see the stack trace that
caused the layout to happen you don't
get that from here either but what you
do get is this really really in-depth
thread by thread breakdown of what's
going on on the GPU thread versus the
compositor thread and you can begin to
see where bottlenecks are actually
happening at at a more fine-grained
level so back before all these tools
though you know measuring rendering
performance in JavaScript was like
comically bad if you mirror that earlier
slide there's all that stuff that
happens outside of JavaScript there's
almost native stuff so if you try to
measure it from JavaScript you get
ridiculous results like this where it's
like off by 2x or 3x it's just
completely ridiculous useless data and
back before things like the FPS meter
and the timeline panel were
well-established this is the kind of
terrible data you got and so this leads
us to our last and craziest hack in the
Dom rendering column back in the day
like say 2011 before there was an FPS
meter available what could you do to get
these orange bars to get the actual
accurate data when javascript is so far
off the mark and we developed a number
of people actually were not the only
ones we developed a really ridiculous
idea that looks like this that's not a
regular SLR camera that's a camera that
shoots video at 600 frames per second
and of course if you give engineers a
toy like this inevitably we're gonna
shoot some video that looks like this
before we get any real work done it's a
guy breathing fire obviously but
eventually we decided we should probably
try to be productive and we eventually
decided to shoot video that looks more
like this this is me hitting a key as
fast as I can
slow down 20 times and you can see
there's a noticeable delay between my
fingers striking the key and the
character
on the screen so you can get extremely
extremely precise information about
things like rendering latency using this
kind of technique obviously this is a
last resort it's really time consuming
to do this so you should prefer to use
the timeline panel the frame per second
meter requestanimationframe base timing
these more modern things that are
available but there are a few cases I
think where this is still useful things
like latency for example again are
trickier to measure the frames per
second meter tells you frequency but not
wait and see another thing that's really
powerful about it though is it actually
lets you measure the performance of apps
where you don't have access to the code
so I think we're very used to in the
JavaScript world you can bring up any
webpage and pull up developer tools on
it start poking around in the code but
let's say you're building like a mobile
website or code Cordova based mobile app
and you want to compare your performance
against a native phone app that's your
competitor you don't have access to the
native code you can't instrument it so a
technique like this would actually let
you measure the performance of the
native app and compare that against your
web-based app so in cases like that
world though this is crazy as a last
resort it can still come in handy
alright so we're done talking about the
rendering column let's switch over and
talk about things that go on inside of
v8 now and I think that probably
everybody knows about the profiler panel
at least a little bit in v8 or sorry in
the developer tools but actually I think
that for memory profiling the timeline
panel is a great first place to start
there are four things that this gives
you that are really really handy the
first is you get this if you switch to
the memory view you get this overview
across the whole timeline capture of
memory usage over time so you can start
to see patterns like memory leaks right
increasing constantly you can see
excessive object turn if you're getting
a GC sort of sawtooth too frequently you
also get this count at the bottom which
is counting the number of Dom related
objects specifically which is one of the
more dangerous sources of memory leaks
because of how much native browser stuff
is prevented from getting freed by
holding on to Dom objects then you can
also see individual GC events
highlighted as individual tick marks
here so you can actually quantify how
much time your JavaScript is frozen from
being executed by a GC going on and then
lastly for any individual yellow bar in
the timeline that's showing JavaScript
execution recent versions of chrome
actually show you the size of the number
of objects that were generated during
the execution that
javascript so you can again start to get
a sense of how much object turn is going
on and at a pretty fine-grained level
and then of course moving into the more
standard memory profiling view hopefully
everybody knows you can you can take a
memory snapshot and begin delving into
it something that might be a little less
widely known though is that you can
actually take multiple snapshots and dip
them in this view so this is really
really useful for looking at memory
leaks you can basically take one
snapshot do an operation that you expect
to be memory neutral like open and close
something and then take a second
snapshot and get a diff and all the unjú
seed objects hanging around between
those two snapshots are red flags are
potential sources of memory leaks so
let's talk about CPU profiling which is
of course the other sort of JavaScript
performance oriented side of the
profiling world this is getting a little
more exotic there's something that just
landed in Chrome Canary recently called
the flame chart view so if you capture a
CPU profile you can get this really cool
visualization of the data and what's
nice about this is that unlike the
normal CPU profile view which buckets
all of the entire profiling run into one
data capture this actually shows you how
the hotspots of area over time so
there's two different panels here
basically and it's a little tricky to
sort them out but basically the top
panel here is an overview of the entire
profile capturing run and the spikes
here are basically showing you
JavaScript activities so the y-axis is
you know increased CPU usage essentially
and then you can zoom in on a particular
part of that like the highlighted area
here and you'll see along the bottom you
get this zoomed in view and this
actually the y-axis means something
different though his rig is confusing
the y-axis here is just is just a stack
call stack basically so it's a lot like
the chrome tracing view where it's a
call stack it's just actually flipped
upside down in this case but same
difference so the the x-axis here
represents time so the wider the bar the
more time spent just like the chrome
tracing view so the x-axis here roughly
maps to the y-axis up in this other
chart that's a little confusing the
other thing that's potentially confusing
about this is the color scheme combined
with the name flame chart makes it sound
kind of like a heat map like red is bad
and green
good that's actually not true at all the
colors here are just like chrome tracing
where they're essentially randomly
chosen colors that the same method gets
the same color everywhere it appears
just to make it easier to read but the
colors don't have any particular meaning
other than that so if you want to start
getting more sort of honing in on very
specific you know parts of your code
base to target for performance profiling
there are two really cool ways that you
can do that the first is you can use
consult up profile and profile end to
actually automatically kick off
profiling sessions to get recorded in
the dev tools and show up with your own
label you can actually have more than
one of these running at once they can be
overlapping they don't have to be
strictly nested so it's a really great
way to begin you know honing down on
specific parts of your code without
having to click the begin and end button
manually right at the right times and
then also you can use console time and
time end to add custom annotations that
show up in the chrome tracing view so
there you can actually begin to see your
own method calls your own time brackets
basically precisely lined up with what's
going on in the browser native side of
things in this really really rich rich
threaded view of what's going on so
again you know like the custom
annotations in the timeline panel these
are really cool ways to begin adding
your own annotations to a data set that
normally is kind of blind to what your
code means and is this very generic view
and here you can begin to make it much
more specific to your own profiling
needs your own goals and targets all
right let's say none of that stuff is
crazy enough let's dial up the craziness
meter a little bit further here if that
stuff isn't giving enough information it
turns out that v8 s-- profiler actually
produces a lot more info than what the
dev tools show and there are a few kind
of crazy hacky ways that you can get at
some of that richer info the set up for
this is a little bit involved that's why
this is on the high end of the crazy
spectrum so I won't go through that in
detail but I'll post up those steps
later but basically what you do is once
you get that set up you close all
instances of chrome that you have open
that includes canary and stable if you
happen to have both open thanks to a
John mcCutchan at Google for helping me
to figure that one out is very confusing
clothes every chrome process you can get
your hands on and when they're all
closed you go to the command line and
you launch Chrome with these special
flags
and they basically get fed through to v8
and tells v8 to generate a log file then
you dig out that log file and you run
this plot timer events script on it
which is part of the v8 source and it
generates a ping file it'll chug for a
little while and spit out this ping file
next to the log and it looks like this
looks a little bit like the chrome
tracing view but rather than being
concerned with browser rendering
performance this is all about what's
going on on the v8 side of things and
you can get really really fine grained
detail here like for example do you see
compactor and GC scavenger you can
actually see when GC activity is going
on when garbage collection is going on
is it garbage collecting from the young
space or the old space is it basically
is it garbage collecting objects that
were recently created and didn't leave
very long or is it getting rid of
objects that hung around a long time and
then all of a sudden all got freed it
was that can be a very very interesting
insight to have into what's going on and
with GC performance problems another
thing that's really cool in this view is
this bar that runs along the middle here
which tells you the kind of code being
executed and what that means is whether
v8 is currently running optimized code
or unoptimized code which can be very a
very important problem if your code
that's performance sensitive isn't
getting optimized fully by v8 that can
be a problem and it can be sort of a
mystery too and the way you tell it by
the my screen is optimized read full
code they call it is it is unoptimized
this particular trace is not such a good
example it's mostly neither it's mostly
not bottleneck by JavaScript at all but
in things that are bottlenecking on
javascript you'll see a lot of either
red or green
hopefully green but maybe red and so to
begin looking at it the first thing you
need to do is actually zoom in on this
data because if you look at this it's
capturing it's really hard to see the
numbers but it's basically 14 seconds is
the only thing this capture one it's the
entire time that chrome is up and
running you don't get any any control
over how long it runs the capture for
the whole time it's it's up and running
so to zoom in on this you can pass some
arguments to that the plot timer events
function and you can basically begin
zooming in so you can see now it's sort
of starting to break down if these frame
units again and you can zoom in even on
a single frame and start to get really
really detailed information you know
down to the millisecond basically about
what's going on inside a v8 at every
little time slice this is still kind of
a crappy iterative process like
have to like run the script and then
relook at the ping file and run the
script again and all that I did come up
with an interesting hack for it
navigating this data more interactively
it's a little tricky it requires pulling
a chunk of code out of the plot timer
event script that you run and basically
getting it to save its intermediate file
before generating the ping it turns out
that the intermediate file that it uses
to generate the ping is just a text
format file that contains a bunch of
drawing commands and if you cross out
the first line if you delete that first
line from the file you can then open
this in an interactive visualizer so
gnuplot is the thing it uses you can you
can get interactive visualizers onto
this new platform at data and I'll show
you a quick example of that here's where
the control scheme from chrome tracing
the video game style thing starts to
sound less crazy because I find this
even more bizarre the way that you
navigate this is you you control mouse
wheel to zoom in which seems pretty
reasonable and this is actually quite
powerful because it's because this is a
data plotting software package you
notice it's smart enough to keep the
axis labels interview even as you zoomed
in which is pretty cool but the way that
you scroll horizontally is you see I
have to refer to notes as how crazy this
is you have to you hold down shift and
you use the mouse wheel to scroll
horizontally and then to scroll
vertically you hold down alt and use the
mouse wheel makes tons of sense right
it's such an intuitive way of navigating
data but it is nonetheless a much faster
iteration than having to repeatedly look
at the milliseconds and then rerun the
script and open the ping file again and
you know rinse and repeat so this is
kind of a cool way to visualize the data
of course because this is just a text
format I think it would be really
awesome if someone wrote like a Java
Script in d3 based visualization of this
or something like that I'll definitely
buy a case of beer for anyone who I can
sort that out or for that matter anyone
who checks it into the dev tools
hopefully one of those two things will
happen to happen soon so once you've
actually zoomed in enough and been able
to identify some data there and let's
say you can actually see that some
things aren't getting optimized when you
want them to be optimized first you
don't know what code that actually is
you just you can see a red bar and you
want to know what functions they are so
one way to get more info on that is to
run that same log file through a
slightly different command it spits out
a text file that looks like this
at first glance this looks a lot like
the data you get out of the regular
tools profiler panel it's just kind of a
you know top-down heavy heavy daylight
you know list of functions but it has
this extra little annotation the
asterisk is telling you that those
functions are running optimized in the
VM the lack of an asterisk tells you
that the function is running unoptimized
and that is probably the red bar you're
looking at if you're seeing a lot of red
in your code it's gonna be the heavy
function that's not optimized so now you
know which function the next question is
why is it not running optimized because
that can be a total mystery you could
make random changes and see if it fixes
things but if you're really desperate
you'd like to get some kind of clue as
to what's up and why it didn't get
optimized and that's where the third v8
logging trick comes in you run Chrome is
slightly different flags and it actually
barks out a bunch of stuff the console
so you redirect it to a text file and
when you search that text file you start
seeing things like this and you can
actually see names of some of your own
functions in there and it'll actually
give you the reason in sort of shorthand
it'll give you the reason why that
function was ineligible for being
optimized or maybe in some cases why it
was optimized and then later on kicked
back and D optimized because it violated
some assumption that v8 was making about
its control flow this stuff is is again
this is like on the extreme end of the
crazy scale because of not only the
complicated set up but also the data
file that you get here is pretty hard to
parse through the reasons that it lists
are often pretty vague and from what
I've seen it seems to not always list
all of the functions that you expect it
to list so sometimes it may be missing
information so it's pretty hard to parse
through if you don't know the v8 source
code which I certainly don't but
hopefully a lot of this data is going to
begin bubbling up you know into views
like chrome tracing and even the dev
tools proper B you know as this stuff
coming out of v8 gets richer and more
stable and there's just so much need for
this to be exposed at a higher level so
I think we'll start seeing more of this
in the near future in actual UI oriented
tools so with all that said sometimes
you should ignore everything I talked
about and in fact everything anyone says
about JavaScript performance because
some things that sometimes they're
reasons to not focus on JavaScript
performance at all but to focus on other
things so reason number one I'll give
you three what I think are three good
reasons to not be always focus on
JavaScript performance
number one is that sometimes Network i/o
performance is a much much bigger issue
page load time is often one of the
number one complaints about slowness
that users have and that often has very
little to do with JavaScript has to do
with network performance and
minimization things like that and there
are a couple really cool browser API to
let you get an info about page load
timing like this one that's information
that is really hard to gather either on
your server or using regular JavaScript
without the help of this browser API
because you don't have insight into the
whole flow from the time the user clicks
a link to the time that this stuff
renders on-screen the browser knows that
whole timeline and they can save the
data and give it to you you can also get
data broken down by individual resources
so you can use these api's to get at the
loading time of individual image files
individual script files all that stuff
the working group that oh sorry this one
thing is going to say about this is that
perceived performance is often more
important than actual performance so
when you're talking to a server and the
server might be slow doing that in a way
that's asynchronous and doesn't block
any part of your pages UI is is a huge
huge win if you look at the way that you
know things like Google Docs or Trello
or Gmail do saves asynchronously in the
background of that blocking stuff it
makes it feel a lot faster even though
it could take several seconds for the
server to actually respond quick aside
the w3c working group that produced
those resource timing API is that I
showed you on this slide here they're
also beginning work now on a number of
AP is for rendering performance for
measuring that stuff programmatically so
they're beginning to basically
standardize things like the scrolling
simulation API that I mentioned earlier
with the chrome telemetry stuff so I
think we'll see a lot of cool stuff out
of this working group in the future this
is also the group that produced
requestanimationframe so we've gotten a
lot of good things out of them already I
think reason number two is that maybe
your code is good enough already I think
that sometimes there's a tendency in
some parts of JavaScript community to
started to jump the gun about
performance for example if someone might
see code like this and say oh geez you
can't do that look at this you're
entering a function closure every
iteration of loop and I mean look what
Jesper comm says about this it's way
faster to just use a regular for loop
and while there's some truth to that if
you look at the time scale on these
things sometimes you're talking about
the difference between 12 meeting 12
million iterations per sec
eighty million iterations per second and
if the context of your code is for
example creating a menu you know that
that difference makes no difference
right if you're only it going to iterate
a couple hundred even a couple thousand
times
that's that difference is just totally
water under the bridge so you know it's
not a best practice to make your code
harder to read or harder to maintain
just for speculative performance gains
the best practice is to identify
specific bottlenecks that your users
actually care about and make fixes for
those in a targeted way
lastly reason number three engineering
time is a finite resource and you should
spend time on what's most important so
here are some things that might be more
important than working on performance
it's a pretty good list right but
sometimes performance really does matter
and when that is the most important
thing to work on I hope that the tools I
showed you will make your life easier
when you get desperate with performance
stuff thanks for listening
[Applause]
you